[音楽]
[笑い]
ふはっはっ
毒だら中だ皆様若い者たちが乗りに乗って人をお祝いするとき何を使うかわかります
でしょうかそう
暗くあ私クラッカーはたくさんまとめて引っ張ったりいろんなことをやってきたんです
けども大きい cracker ってあるじゃないですか
ちょっと持っておきましょうなんだこいつですねべかご覧くださいこれ
梅雨のサイズが50倍らしいです
すごい別レイヤーそこでこの私外れ子たちははタックスはじめ雪にはたくさんの増収が
いる受けなさの女性の中でもいろんなタイプの上昇がいるのだから中でもパリッタイル
の助手
圭佑という男がいる県勢はやはりパリぴぱーりーぴー無難でパニーが好き
そんな彼さっき誕生日を迎えてしまって洞窟はじめの女将のパーティー p 高の
誕生日
これ
野地盛大に祝わなければいけないということで今回はこの教材でクラッカーたくさん
準備しました
こいつはヤバイですほぼ花火ですはい
届いてみたところ80個くらいの巨大なクラッカーがありますで1個あたりが
クラッカーの威力が普通のクラッカーの50倍つまり号10倍のクラッカーがはずじっ
くあるって事は
よ先輩4コマって俺いえなかで打ち明け並びするようなもんだな出位のクラッカー
パーンてやる奴でも4000倍ねぇ弱のカッターで後輩の女子のたグルルバウとを貼っ
ポストっとリア表
キュッパいてみる早速威力4000マイルクロックを作っていきましょう今回難しく
なるポイントまあこれだけ大量のクラッカーを一発で飛ばすということそして全部通し
た
ユニークでやりたいということでなかなか簡単にはできませんまずは土台の準備し
ましょう
こちらの白いかなみ私のイメージとしてはこのかなりいい感じでクラックが入るんです
こういう感じで完璧じゃね定款で国家なぁミニめちゃくちゃ cracker を今
から差していきますでその際にしっかりこれで日も出しながらさしていきますファー
よしっイヤーさあ花を沢山のせ
ていきましょう
これすごいて nikko で50倍だからにこいてる時点でこれ100倍ですからね
はいはいこういう感じでどんどんさせていきましょう
ちょっと魂ができたのでこのままととひっくり返すとても落ちちゃうんで
1回亀てるなので固めます
[音楽]
ってねえちょっといびつですが多分大丈夫です逆算でいきましょう
去年絶対確定見れなかったですみなさん l 時は覚えておいてくださいね
ねぇ
あっ配球で全部じゃないんですけどもほとんどだから彼はこちらに設置することが完了
しましたね次は下に行きますが昔もやったんですけどモカラッタの紐があまりに多
すぎるんで2角紐を一つにしていきますしまってそもそもクラッカーがヒトマル際に
必要な動画前の数が減るので2つを1つにしていきます
配球が出来ましたこれでひもの数が走行つくなくなりました
次のステップへ行きましょう
ああこういう
ブーブーますとすべての日もう一つにするためにはさらにこの2つにしまったこういう
のを縛る3しますつまり4つの日もう一つにしていきますこういう日を使ってこうやっ
てえっなーれっかーじゃあねと言います
ほら1本になった
ok ですできましたこれだけ僕はかなり付けなくなりました
もうちょっと残ってるでつけるところにはつけていきましょう
はいというわけで結構サマになってきたと思いますねもう一息ですはいでここがさらに
この細い紐またまとめていきます
を7はね全部1個地といえばいいんですよってかそれが目的
[音楽]
た分だけですこれでも引っ張られてますし
てかさーあああいてるという感じました普通のクラッカー
パンの要点パネル鉱物最強の
このまず花火だな花火ですとしてお見せしたいポイントがこちらもいろいろめっちゃ
言葉としてるんですけども全部前ことまとめてこちらの動線1個にまとめあげました
これいっぱいばもう全部
つきますはいああいう強いようやく完成しました
このクラッカードンキで全部買ったんですよカウントすぐ売り切れになっちゃうから私
のと覚えては会長
ではかりっていうその作業も食べ4ヶ月じゃやっててようやく
本中集まりました
[音楽]
取り替えやもん先輩のクラックをぶつけて最高のに実際にしてあげようと思います会は
以降んねむずいんだよなぁひっくり返すんで怖いんだよな
モテない気がしてきたな
4愛知愛知愛
おっと誰も試合にあるやる買えるから買っていうか
援交誤って動く大丈夫か本当にもうくるようであります
間に強い権限を賛助会だぞや
それバー
はぁ
ああああああ
[音楽]
やわー
me
teame
ni
me
uh
喜んでもらえて何よりだがいいか壊滅状態ですよね木谷にもうなんか
床が変わった色がう
一周にしてちょっと何言ってるかわかんない猫
水らしくドクターズに実験成功だーですじゃぁ後片付け任せたあるってあーこれはー
[拍手]